amenez-le jusqu'au bout, vous n'avez
jamais vu un camion comme celui-ci avant
papa, il continue de dépenser de l'argent en bric-à-brac, ce
truc est ce qui va vous permettre d'aller à l'
université, ma fille devient un peu
frustrée que je poursuive mon rêve d'
être un inventeur
alors quand  Je tombe sur ce camion, son premier
instinct est juste de se débarrasser de cette
chose Je ne pense pas que ce soit un camion du tout
Je pense que nous venons de trouver un transformateur
Personne ne comprend l'ampleur des
ramifications de ce que le gouvernement
fera à quiconque détient  sur
elle, le transformateur, nous avons une règle sur le fait de
jouer avec les gens du Texas quand je
vous ai demandé une fois où est Optimus
Prime,
cela lui donne une excellente raison de se lever
et d'être un héros pour protéger sa petite
fille,
il n'y a pas d'essayer de régler les choses
pacifiquement  donc je dois tout faire pour
protéger ma fille
je suis Michael Bay film